lundi 16 mars veille du confinement ses
bureaux étaient pleins les
collaborateurs de cette pme spécialisée
dans le matériel et la maintenance
informatique était sur le pont en une
journée cette entreprise a réalisé un
chiffre d'affaires normalement réalisé
sur une semaine énormément de
d'entreprises qui ne s'était pas du tout
préparés au confinement qui normalement
ne demande entreprises pour mettre en
place des accès distants des réseaux
pour s'équiper en ordinateurs portables
mais aussi en webcam un micro casque
dans cette zone commerciale c'est le
seul commerce à avoir l'autorisation
d'être ouvert l'activité de cette pme se
poursuit elle continue à recevoir des
clients notamment ce chef d'entreprise
pas notre client a besoin de faire du
télétravail est donc en fait on va lui
fournir un écran supplémentaire pour
pouvoir connecter son ordinateur
portable est en fait avoir deux écrans
pour faire justement toutes les tâches
administratives là en urgence je viens
chercher du matériel en complément et
j'ai mes bureaux qui sont à côté aux
essarts-le-roi où je bosse à distance
tout seul pour pouvoir faire avancer mon
entreprise tant qu'elle peut avancer
maintenant sur site il ya deux personnes
à notre magasin de versailles et deux
personnes dont moi même ici à coignières
pour servir les clients qui ont des
pannes qui ont besoin de webcams de
casques d'ordinateurs portables ou faire
réparer leur matériel depuis le
confinement la majorité des salariés
sont en télétravail durant cette
première semaine beaucoup d'activités
entre 100 à 150 demandes quotidiennes de
télémaintenance
chaque jour est différent et on va voir
la semaine prochaine
comment on va s'organiser pour maintenir
donc une continuité d'activité mais
aussi adapter les équipes à la demande
pour le moment l'activité se maintient
mais si la crise se poursuit sur
plusieurs mois
cette pme pourrait connaître des
conséquences plus lourdes